meron ka bang sariling negosyo
plano mo bang magtayo ng sarili mong negosyo
kung ang sagot ay yes
then makinig kang mabuti kasi kakailanganin mo to
kailangan mong mahanap ang perfect na target market
para sa negosyo mo
pero ano nga ba
ang mga bagay na nagdedefine ng target market
ang target market ay binubuo ng dalawang bagay
ang demo graphics at psychographics
sa video na to sisimulan natin sa demographics
so ito ang mga bumubuo sa demographics
number one
age ano ang age range
ng mga customer
na posibleng bumili ng produkto o ng service mo
pangalawa
gender ano nga ba ang kasarian
ng target market mo or ng audience mo
number three
education
ano nga ba ang pinakamataas na pinag aralan
ng target market or ng audience mo
number four
family status
single ba sila
married ba sila divorced ba sila
may mga anak ba sila
number five
interests ano nga ba ang hilig ng mga audience mo
mahilig ba sila sa food
mahilig ba sila magtravel
mahilig ba sila sa business
kailangang malaman niyo rin ito
number six
location
kailangang alam niyo
kung saan nakatira ang audience niyo
this includes the country
the city
the province and even the barangay
number seven
income kailangang alam niyo rin
kung magkano ang kinikita ng audience niyo
napakahalaga nito
lalong lalo na
sa pag determine ng pricing
ng product or service ninyo
number eight
social media
kailangang alam niyo to
para malaman niyo kung saan kayo magmamarket
sa facebook ba
to sa instagram ba to sa tiktok ba to
sa youtube ba to or even sa google ba
number nine propesyon
nasa anong industriya or ano yung line of work
ng audience or potential clients ninyo
number ten and last but not least
networks
saan nga ba tumatambay or naghahang out
yung mga potential clients ninyo
may be online or offline
leave a comment
kung ano po yung gusto niyong matutunan
about marketing
and of course
follow for more tips